oh  yeah this was a very unexpected choice  bayern  and  maybe in the picture we also see that  let's see if we can  uh he can uh  you can calculate his way up out of this  somehow  and what did i say icarus was gonna have  about 40 minutes so he has 43. he has a  little bit more  so that bolts well for him  [Music]  as well 40 minutes for about 20 moves  and  in a very good position  sounds  i mean  i'm not sure he's going to have a really  difficult decision for the rest of the  game the way it's going  so  fabi looked very interested there  just looks beautiful  whoa  okay by the way the line i was talking  about with bishop c2 that's obviously  nonsense because of queen d2  so  yeah queen g6 uh is 9